in examining especially second-wave
feminist ik discourse is clear the
premises the premises there are physical
differences Simone de Beauvoir makes
that candidly clear there are physical
differences between men and women we
know them we're not ignorant to them
she even mentions emotional differences
in her book the second sex and her
chapter on biology she says even
biological differences anatomical
differences physiological differences
psychological differences emotional
differences but the argument goes as
follows despite those differences there
should be equality does that make sense
so far so if a second-rate feminist
would say despite those differences
there should be equality afforded
what kind of equality political equality
social equality economic equality this
is pretty much in a nutshell what the
argument is now obviously one could
justifiably ask what's the proof of that
what's the evidence for that why should
that be the case how's that entailment
made from first principles Rousseff
supports how can you justify that
and that's really not a question that
there is any answer to frankly well that
there is any formula given for us on how
to answer those questions however and
this is moving on now to the second part
of the lecture which are to spend a
little bit of time on are we consistent
or are feminists consistent in
particular second where families are
they consistent in the application of
those principles now there are three
things three live examples I want to
give you to show you how problematic
these assumptions are for feminists the
first one relates and I'm sure many of
you might have been exposed to this it's
a big thing on the news now actually
that's why I'm bringing it up it's the
idea of transgendered sports now I'm not
sure if this is kind of them spill over
to Malaysia but this is certainly
something a hot topic in the West in
America and in the UK Western Europe the
question is say for instance you have
someone who identifies and who is
identified biologically as a man they do
a gender reassignment surgery and they
become self-identified as a woman okay
so they do a gender reassignment surgery
and then become self-identified as a
woman can they participate in sports
with women now second wave feminists on
the whole seem averse to the idea now
you can't make a generalization with
anything but big-time second wave
feminists like Germaine Greer who wrote
the book in 1971 the Female Eunuch
she's like one of the founding mothers
of feminism and she in an interview she
completely rejected the idea and guess
what she invoked she invoked anatomical
and biological advantage wait a minute
hold on now hold on now let me hear the
argument yes so the argument goes now
since the person and this is a very
sensible argument to me as a non
feminist right the argument goes since
men have anatomical biological
advantages hormonal advantages and even
having gone through that process and
then the assignment the gender
reassignment happens if they now compete
with women it will give them an unfair
advantage and it will give them an
entitled over privileged position in
that context wait a minute this is
important now I thought you said sex was
or not sex because that's a third wave
construct some say that sex is a social
construct Judith Butler hinted to this
in her book gender troubles 1990 but not
this some do say that I thought you said
gender was a social construct no and you
know it becomes even more problematic do
you know when it becomes more
problematic when we start to see so the
question is now should there be an
equality of opportunity for men and
women in certain sports should we or
should we segregate and separate them
you don't like segregation but you have
it in sports but no no it's justified
for anatomical and biological reasons so
you're saying they're on biological and
anatomical grounds you can justify
separation wait hold on now but men will
be given an advantage why don't you make
that argument in all context of
categories for instance if you look at
the hundred meter dash and I made this
argument before I make here again the
100 meter sprints in the last 100 years
I don't know of one why
man who's won that no I don't know I
don't know one white man that's one that
it's dominated by black people not only
does black people West Africans and
Jamaicans should we separate the blacks
from the whites now if you say we
shouldn't separate the blacks from the
whites you're contradicting yourself you
know why because you said in cases where
there is biological and anatomical
advantages for one category of person
over another category of person there
should be separation so why should that
be the case only for gender why
shouldn't it also be the case for race
because you've recalled racist
this is selective invocation you see
they are not even consistent with their
principles these Africans are very good
at long-distance you know we have
someone called noir Farah very good
runner you know they have an advantage
East Africans birth early they have a
broadening advantage white people have
an advantage in something swimming and I
want to be controversial but I've never
seen a black man win that swimming race
I was at world market Michael Phelps how
many sons do you on it while we're gonna
separate the blacks from the whites
we're not going to separate the blacks
from the whites so what kind of
equalities you wanna so some feminists
would say we want equality of
opportunity and some would actually say
we want equality of outcome all right so
yeah some would say we want any quality
of opportunity but almost all feminists
would say that in fact so why don't you
have an equality of opportunity in
sports
why don't we arrange parameters that
mean that people of the same weights
whether they're men and women they go
together in competition we can do that
it's not difficult it's not difficult in
boxing for example you don't think
there's 75 kilogram women that's the
most popular category for men let's
bring them together right you want
equality of opportunity
no but that's advantage men but he said
the anatomical thing you see it is
really problematic
you have segregation acquiesce
segregation in some spheres where are
the feminists we needs we need a sign
against this seriously if your preview
are principally averse to a biological
anatomical arguments arranged parameters
which does not discriminate on gender in
the field of sports but they will never
do that because it's not about equality
it's about entitlement it's about where
can we find the advantages that's the
problem and this case becomes more
exacerbated when we look at war we need
to rectify the social ills problems of
the past patriarchal society and we need
to have equality of opportunity in all
spheres in all industries political
social and economic there should be
absolutely no exception to that but war
that entails death that entails injury
we don't really know about that one I've
never actually come across their
movements that aims to rectify a
historic accumulation of gender
discrimination against men in the field
of war almost every military in every
country in the world in all of history
has been male-dominated men have died
now if we're being honest we should say
that's a severe matriarchy you're forced
meant to be society inclined or forced
to kill themselves and fight themselves
so for the protection of the country so
on feminism if there's an equality of
opportunity we should address that
historic discrimination and we should
look at all the wars that men were
dominating the armies in them and we
should have female only conscription and
draft forcing the women to fight for the
men for at least the amount of time that
would equalize the historic imbalance no
but brother which are being flooded by
males men is that extra words the actual
maitreya watch before mecca for the meat
to go to Milan talks
what kind of things is what the most
part so if we're going
nobody quality first should we rectify
that the program is guys no it's just to
selective you choose want to be
absolutely equal and you choose you're
in session this is the problem so these
are some clear examples of
inconsistencies even using the first
principles of feminism even using
exactly what they're talking about